in March when the majority of American
businesses were forced to closed due to
the corona virus outbreak one industry
that's still seeing somewhat a float is
the cannabis industry during the week of
March 16th cannabis dispensaries and
legal states across the country started
seeing their sales surge this was
largely due to the initial stock up
mentality when the fate of dispensary
operations was then still unclear but
now with stay at home orders sweeping
the nation through May at minimum and
cannabis dispensaries deemed essential
business sales are actually fluctuating
between decreasing and stable as more
people are limiting their shopping
outings and their spending
however retailers are seeing customer
order amounts increase per transaction
which are averaging 62 dollars per
basket across all legal states this is a
20 percent increase to individual
transactions during an average
pre-pandemic day in 2020 there's some
interesting stats here
so when Denver for example prohibited
cannabis we saw 392 percent spike in
sales following you know week later
March 28th through 329 saw it overall
25% decrease in cannabis sales compared
to the weekends before the köppen 19
outbreak this simply means people
bloated up on cannabis and now they're
using their products without going back
to the store so I think we're pretty
we're now stabilized drip but I think
we'll probably continue to see buying in
bulk and then using the cannabis
products right stayed at home buying
bulk staying at home right so I think
that's probably the new pattern we're
gonna see in a retail the corona virus
outbreak has also caused a shift in
spending habits with consumers having
less disposable income or just facing
fears of inhaling smoke dollars are
moving away from flower and towards
smokeless products like edibles the
category itself is up 30% in the past
two months
we literally doubled sales from February
to March and we anticipate seeing it
even further increase coming into April
we're in a unique position because you
know not only is you know marijuana
considered an essential business and
people are flocking to kind of stock up
on that but secondary because we're also
a product you know people are also kind
of shifting away from smoking their
products and using other bait type you
know usually just so edibles are seen a
nice little surge as a whole as well you
know on top of the exterior that's the
marijuana industry scoot the whole stay
at home order really allow us people to
try new product people aren't staying at
home so if they you know take an edible
and it affects them for you know four to
six hours you know they don't have to
worry about I'm going to work or they
don't have to worry about you know other
responsibilities so you know people are
you know a wide range of people are
trying them and I think that after it's
all said and done more people than
before will remain active users the
sharp declines in the back half of March
suggests that sales for the full month
of April could fare even worse even as
consumers might still be celebrating the
4/20 holiday at home amid the
coronavirus driven downturn several
large publicly traded cannabis companies
like acreage Holdings med men canopy
growth and forefront ventures have been
forced to scale back operations and lay
off workers to cut costs although
cannabis has been deemed essential on a
state level a new challenge has emerged
the marijuana industry is unable to tap
into federal stimulus packages or even
bank loans this lack of a safety net
access to banking or the ability to get
federal dollars despite being taxpayers
means that a slight misstep could lead
to bankruptcy for many small companies
cannabis does remain a very popular
medicine it helps people sleep better
and helps with anxiety these are things
that people are having trouble with
right now sleeping and being anxious so
you know I think we'll see cannabis
actually sustained potentially even
better than alcohol well through this
you know Cove lid pandemic that could go
on for a very long time
for the most part you know cannabis has
kind of been on the sideline in terms of
being recognized as an essential part of
healthcare and I feel like the ascent it
being essential will shift the way the
entire nation of use cannabis moving
forward